bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches ne
vous étonnez pas estelle n'est pas
malade mais elle reviendra dès la
semaine prochaine
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du coronavirus remarqué nous
avons monté nos masques pour ça bonjour
olivier bonjour à tous émission donc
exclusivement consacré au cours d'un
virus et plus exactement aux
conséquences sur l'économie mondiale de
ce que l' oms qualifie désormais de
pandémie alors avant de détailler les
différents impacts olivier un mot sur la
situation générale quel regard vous
portez sur ce que l'os et des cris je
cite comme le plus grave danger depuis
la crise financière
alors c'est pas le plus grave danger
depuis la crise financière c'est en fait
c'est le révélateur c'est le catalyseur
d'une situation qui n'a jamais été réglé
depuis 2008 on a mis la poussière sous
le tapis on a fait semblant
on a mis beaucoup d'argent sur la table
pour que le système ait l'air de tenir
et aujourd'hui on a un événement qu'on
attendait pas simyo noir qu'on
n'attendait pas et qui arrivent et qui
joue les révélateurs de d'une situation
mais qui une situation qui était pourrie
depuis longtemps couvait depuis
longtemps sa mairie parce que regarder
par exemple vous avez à l'exemple
japonais l'exemple japonais il vous
sortent une recul du pib de 6 3% sur le
dernier trimestre annualisé évidemment
sur le dernier trimestre 2010 9 sur le
dernier trimestre 2010 9 vous n'aviez
pas le coronavirus vous avez eu une
baisse du commerce international durant
toute l'année 2019 n'y avait pas le
coronavirus non plus si vous voulez donc
il faut pas tout attribuer au corps d'un
virus le coronavirus nous met dans une
situation exceptionnelle parce que là
réellement on n'avait jamais vu ça vous
avez le troisième est que pays de la
zone euro qui est l'italie qui est
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt à l'arrêt avec des
gens qui sont consignés chez eux
si on vous l'avait dit il ya dix ans
vous l'auriez jamais cru et évidemment
ça avait conséquences évidemment ça va
aggraver les choses et
et aujourd'hui je je m'amuse beaucoup
quand j'entends certains économistes de
plateau et le comice de plateau c'est
celui qui n'a jamais rien fait autre
chose que de faire des plateaux de télé
qui qui vous disent que il pense que
peut-être on va entrer en récession on
est en récession
c'est assez flagrant vous pouvez pas
bloquer un pays pendant six mois et vous
dire qu'il va vous sortir un pib positif
c'est sus du rêve donc on est dans la
session il faut savoir qu'une récession
bas ça coûte un peu d'argent sur les
marchés financiers et ça c'est une
évidence l'une des justement des
illustrations de cette crise du
coronavirus sont donc les bourses qui
dévisse l'économie mondiale est en
danger c'est donc l' ocde qu'il dit on
fait le récit de ce lundi noir sur les
marchés financiers c'est le tiroir cash
d'antoine va sas décide et non le court
aux navires us ne nous laisse aucun
répit
en plus de faire peur au monde entier ce
sont maintenant les marchés qui en
pâtissent le plus
le 9 mars restera comme un lundi noir
les bourses des différents pays
s'effondre et on prédit une croissance
fortement ralenti un peu partout tout le
monde attend maintenant les mesures des
banques centrales pour une fois de plus
maintenir l'économie à flot tant bien
que mal la fed la réserve fédérale des
états unis a déjà baissé ses taux d'un
demi point et la banque centrale
européenne bas compliqué de baisser des
taux qui sont déjà au plus bas
alors on fait ce tiroir cash on ne sait
pas encore ce qu'elle va faire mais on
imagine bien christine lagarde nous
sortir une politique
whatever it takes à la mario draghi oh
punaise christine lagarde
elle va nous intéresser celle là c'est
sûr à maurice yacast et la garde
on n'est pas d'être orient
9 mars ce sont les cours du pétrole qui
a enregistré leur plus forte chute
depuis 1991 et la guerre du golfe après
que l'opep et la russie n'ait pas réussi
à s'accorder sur une baisse de la
production pour limiter les dégâts face
à la baisse des transports bref ce
coronavirus déclenché un vrai choc
économique
attendez on n'en n'a pas fini
certains économistes parlent déjà de
crise financière ou de krach boursier
le corona bientôt mais trop dur
voilà donc pour le tiroir cash d'antoine
wasa son va continuer de détailler les
différents impacts économiques de cette
crise et pour cela olivier je vous
propose d'accueillir maintenant notre
invité pierre bentata bonjour pierre
bentata merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
économiste essayiste et collaborateur
chez asterès alors on l'a vu dans le
magnéto dans le tiroir cash d'antoine va
sas le lundi noir sur les marchés
financiers on est en train de vivre en
ce moment un jeudi noir c'est le cas au
moment même où on enregistre cette
émission quel regard vous portez sur la
situation qui est en cours dans les
bourses
c'est ce qui a été très bien dit au
début de votre émission on a en fait on
a un coronavirus qui révèle une crise de
fond une crise structurelle sur les
marchés financiers et la moindre le
moindre problème sur un marché réel le
moindre problème économique qui laisse
penser qu'ils vont avoir une réception
va entraîner un entraîne actuellement le
bouleversement qu'on observe on a
assisté à un arrêt des échanges à wall
street
pouvez nous parler d'eux
cette situation qui est très rare oui
c'est pas anodin en principe quand ça
arrive c'est que vraiment on s'attend à
une panique absolue sur un marché alors
les dernières fois que c'était arrivé
c'était moins grave parce que c'était
simplement des bottes des algorithmes
qui s'était un peu monté le bourrichon
entre eux et qui du coup faisait
exploser des prix donc on a tout calmé
mais là on sait que ce sont des humains
qui s'inquiètent et donc on sait qu'il
ya une vraie panique parce que au fond
personne n'est dupe tout le monde sait
qu'il ya un vrai problème sur les
marchés et j'irai encore plus loin que
ce que vous disiez au début je pense
même pas que ce soit 2008 sa date de
2000 et on vit toujours sur la crise
internet de 2000 olivier vous êtes
d'accord avec ça aux yeux après moi je
veux qu'on pourrait remonter aussi à
ltcm 90,8 et que ça c'est à dire que
depuis ce moment là on a des banquiers
centraux qui ont dit ne vous inquiétez
pas nous vous assurons donc évidemment
si vous voulez cesser on peut faire une
métaphore là dessus s'est expliqué que
vous faites du trapèze volant vous avez
un fils et vous pouvez faire le con
autant que vous voulez parce que vous
savez que vous allez tomber dans le
filet si jamais ça se passe mal si on
vous avait dit à ce moment là j'ai le
cas il n'y a pas de filet là vous y
réfléchissez à deux fois avant de faire
votre saut périlleux parce que vous
savez que si vous vous raté ses
parterres et ben c'est exactement la
même chose au moment de 98 au moment dé
le tcm greenspan arrive et dit ne vous
inquiétez pas papa est là avec son gros
chéquier et il va régler tous les
problèmes et à partir de ce moment là
vous avez les banquiers qui se disent on
a carte blanche parce que toute façon
quoi qu'on fasse comme bêtises on à la
banque centrale qui est derrière et qui
va régler nos problèmes et donc là on
est parti dans quelque chose qui était
complètement débridée avec des gens qui
vous utilisez des effets de levier
énormes en se disant mais toute façon si
on se casse la gueule c'est pas grave
parce qu'il y aura quelqu'un pour payer
la casse et c'est vrai que au final
c'est un modèle magique
1 parce que
face je gagne pile tu perds donc au
final je suis toujours gagnant je me
réparti grassement les gains et quand il
ya des pertes c'est mutualisé c'est le
contribuable qui paye donc on peut pas
rêver mieux comme modèle économique
sauf que évidemment il ya des moments où
ça commence à coincer et là on est à un
moment où ça commence à coincer parce
que c'est pas fini
on a notre secrétaire d'état à
l'économie qui mardi nous disait
investissez dans les actions
on sait déjà pris 15% depuis c'est
merveilleux
ces gens qui savent ce qui ce se croient
des traders et si on sait ce que je vous
disais c'est que une récession normale
c'est 40 % sur un marché donc une
récession plus importante mondial avec
très probablement des choses qu'on ne
connaît pas c'est ce que je vous disais
on n'a jamais vu un pays qui était
arrêté la production et la sky ans hier
en italie notamment baissé énormément
les évidemment mais on sait ce que je
vis on va le tarif qu'on va être obligé
de payer probablement bien plus élevées
30 ou 40% et que on a et à ce moment là
il faut voir les conséquences que ça va
avoir sur les assureurs sur les
banquiers etc sur les fonds de pension
des reculs comme ça de 40 ou de 50 %
alors que ces entités là ont mis du
risque dans leurs portefeuilles parce
qu'elle n'avait plus rien en terme de
rendement sur les obligations
donc elles sont elles sont allées
chercher du risque et aujourd'hui vous
voyez ce que ce que donne le risque donc
ça va ça va faire des dégâts
pire bentata autre aspect de cette crise
du coronavirus un peu plus indirecte
mais quand même lié à la pandémie c'est
la chute du prix du baril de pétrole
alors le 9 mars dernier on était à 33
dollars le baril s'agit de la plus forte
baisse depuis la guerre du golfe en 1991
cette chute est la conséquence des
échecs des négociations notamment lors
du dernier sommet de l'opep
là encore on ne peut y voir un
indicateur
très négatif est ce que c'est lié de
façon très directe ce coronavirus non
c'est pas liée directement mais par
contre évidemment ça va rajouter encore
plus de tension sur les nez sur les
marchés et ça c'est certain que vous
avez vous cumulez ici le début d'une
crise pétrolière ou le début d'un
conflit pétroliers avec une panique sur
les marchés qui en fait
et pour bien comprendre parce qu'à la
limite ça ça peut se résoudre par un
effet de communication par un accord
mais il faut pour bien comprendre ce
qu'ils qui ce qu'on va vivre
est ce qu'il va falloir faire il faut
comprendre d'où vient vraiment le
problème quand vous disiez que on a une
on a en fait assuré on a créé un
phénomène d'aléa moral où tout le monde
prend des risques parce que personne ne
les supporte
le problème c'est que quand bien même ça
aurait lieu la raison pour laquelle
s'est rendue possible c'est qu'il ya
plein d'argent
il ya trop d'argent c'est vraiment les
quantitative easing qui ont créé ça et
même si on avait des entreprises ou des
fonds qui avaient pas envie de se
comporter d'une façon opportuniste de
faire n'importe quoi ou de prendre trop
de risques en fait ils sont quasiment
contraint de le faire parce que quand
vous avez une telle masse de monnaie qui
allaient que sur les marchés financiers
parce que personne ne l'utilisait et
qu'en fait les robinets été coupées par
les banques
tout le monde a pu investir partout et
donc on à brouiller le signal prix ddd
valeur des différentes actions et on ne
comprend plus qu'à l'entreprise est
risquée laquelle ne l'est pas et c'est
ça qui crée la vraie panique c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus personne ne sait si
ces positions sont risqués ou pas et
donc on va on veut on un ralentissement
économique on va avoir une véritable
crise structurelle sur le marché réel
mais sur le marché financier
on va avoir à nouveau comme on l'a vu
précédemment une crise de liquidité
parce que plus personne se prêtent
d'argent et ça ça va finir encore une
fois en récession de bilan tout le monde
va essayer de nettoyer son bilan et donc
le marché va être arrêté et là est le
vrai enjeu là c'est de se dire qu'est ce
que vont faire ici les banques centrales
et les gouvernements si nous refont le
même sketch
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au en 2008
alors on va recréer encore une fois une
bulle encore plus grosse on va venir
justement aux réponses des gouvernements
et de la banque et des banques centrales
un mot d'abord peut-être sur les
entreprises qui ont été concernés
directement par ces chutes dans dans les
bourses
quel impact là on n'est qu'au début
peut-être de cette crise boursière mais
quel impact elle doit avoir pour des
entreprises françaises notamment on
pense à des grosses entreprises et de
grosses pertes pour pour des entreprises
importantes du cac40 en fin
moi je
c'est au delà de ça c'est à dire que si
vous êtes en récession on a on a un vrai
souci qui va être un souci justement de
dette
pourquoi parce que vous avez des
entreprises qui parce que les taux
étaient à 0 se sont surendettés
alors on se disant de toute façon c'est
pas grave ça nous coûte rien puisqu'il
n'y a pas de taux d'intérêt ou très peu
le problème c'est quand vous êtes en
récession ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que votre chiffre d'affaires va reculer
de 10 de 15% et où elle est la
trésorerie pour rembourser les emprunts
elle n'est pas là et ça ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que en première ligne
vous avez qui vous avez les assureurs et
les réassureurs qui sont des mesures de
crédit il faut pas l'oublier un
l'assureur s'est pas simplement un type
qui vous fait de l'assurance sur la
voiture c'est le principalement c'est
l'assurance crédit et l'assurance crédit
lille va y avoir des défauts est assez
largement et derrière vous avez qui vous
avez le banquier et donc c'est là qu'on
risque dans l'est alors ça va pas se
faire tout de suite ça va se faire dans
les six mois qui viennent mais c'est là
qu'on a un vrai risque après les deux
par jour là chut oui après sur la chute
des bourses qui est ce qu'ils ont sous
avait évidemment les banquiers qui sont
pas dans le sens d'un programme vous
traitez agricole près de 17% de
croisière après la brève vous avez aussi
tout ce qui est fonds de pension etc
parce que c'est ce que je vous ai dit
vous avez des énormément de fonds
énormément d'assureurs énormément qui
ont mis du risque parce qu'il n'avait
plus rien pour remplacer des obligations
qu'ils avaient pris il ya dix quinze ans
et qui était à 5 6 7%
eh bien il se retrouvait avec des
obligations taux négatif donc évidemment
ils prenaient pas il leur fallait durant
demandons qu'ils allaient soit sur des
obligations à lille c'est à dire des
obligations très risqué et qui sont en
train de se tendre soit sur des sur des
actions et là vous allez avoir un
massacre
tout ce qui est alors pour revenir un
peu sur le pétrole le pétrole c'est
normal je veux dire dès que vous jouez
une récession
est ce que vous faites vous jouez une
contraction de la demande et à ce moment
là
chez complètement de savoir quelle est
l'offre c'est pour ça que à la limite je
veux dire réduire l'offre de quelques
centaines de milliers barils par jour
c'est pas grave ça ne sert à rien bon et
les marchés jouent quoi ils jouent la
contraction de la demande s'ils jouent
la contraction de la demande qu'est-ce
qui se passe
moi je l'avais annoncé il ya quelques il
ya quelques temps alors que l'ensemble
des experts étaient plutôt vers les 100
dollars et moi j'avais dit on ira à 25
dollars dès qu'on jouera une récession
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
et alors ça avait conséquence c'est que
toutes les banques qui ont prêté au gaz
et au pétrole de schiste aux états unis
qui est la ruine est d'accord toutes ces
banques là elles vont jamais retrouvé
leur fric et donc vous allez avoir des
faillites en cascade
donc c'est là que ça va ça va commencer
à être intéressant mais intéressant au
niveau fondamentaux au niveau économie
réelle
la bourse a honnêtement je vais je vais
je vais enchères green et beaucoup on
s'en fout le cac40 série risque et en
scène par exemple une banque comme on
l'avait vu en 2008 fait faillite
est ce que c'est un scénario auquel on
doit on peut se préparer
je vous lis juste deux déclarations de
l'économiste et je vous fait réagir
pierre bentata gaël giraud économiste et
directeur de recherche au cnrs il ya
deux chances sur trois que l'on vive une
répétition de 2008 sont à parler et puis
philippe waetcher directeur de la
recherche économique chez ostrom à 7
on est au bord d'une récession
économique globale est ce que comme le
disait fort au mieux dedans on est dans
à peu près vives que comme le disait
olivier on peut s'attendre on doit
s'attendre à une faillite
quelque chose des réactions en cascade
oui bien sûr on doit ça dont on doit
s'attendre à des faillites en cascade
parce que si le problème et c'est ça qui
va se passer c'est que on s'aperçoit que
des entreprises en fait non pas les flux
de trésorerie et non pas les profits
qu'ils étaient alignés avec leurs
niveaux de dette
de toute façon elles vont elles vont
couler et donc mécaniquement si ce sont
des grosses c'est une catastrophe
et ici il ya deux il ya de grandes
possibilités de toute façon sera en
effet domino mais pour comprendre ce
qu'est ce qui va devoir faire il faut se
demander où est ce que ça va commencer
soit c'est une très grosse boîte que
tout le monde pensait en très bonne
santé qui s'effondrent c'était
d'autres comme dans la crise de 2000 et
c'est ça qui déclenché la panique dans
un secteur qui contamine tout le reste
soit et c'est encore plus grave
ce sont ces sons des instruments
financiers que tout le monde considérait
comme très valorisant et très profitable
et qui du jour au lendemain en fait
s'avère trop risqué et c'est le cas aux
états unis de ski lui remplace un peu
nos banques à nous ou nos
investissements institutionnels c'est le
cas des fonds indiciels où des gens
mettent vraiment leur argent pour payer
les crédits ensuite étudiants de leurs
enfants ou leurs retraites etc et là vu
que ça s'est alignée est indexé de façon
très passive sur le s p 500 ou sur
d'autres places boursières quand on va
s'apercevoir que sur ces places ya une
incertitude
alors ces fonds là ont rompu une valeur
et là c'est directement les particuliers
qui perdent de l'argent
donc évidemment mécaniquement mais ils
peuvent plus honorer non plus leurs
dettes donc les banques
elle aussi se retrouve en panne de
liquidités et là c'est la catastrophe on
va parler maintenant des réponses ce que
peuvent apporter les gouvernements et
les banques centrales je vous propose
d'abord de regarder ce tweet de donald
trump pour ceux qui parlent beaucoup sur
twitter alors je cite notre réserve
fédérale minable et lente alors c'était
le 10 mars dernier enfin portant de le
préciser notre réserve fédérale minable
et lente dirigé par jeff powell qui a
relevé les taux trop rapidement et
baisser trop tard devrait ramener notre
taux directeur au niveau de ceux de nos
pays concurrents ils ont maintenant un
avantage allant jusqu'à 2 points avec
une aide encore plus importante sur les
devises olivier comment vous interpréter
ce message du président américain
en fait il l'a créée il enfonce une
porte ouverte c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui les faut bien comprendre que
les banques centrales n'ont pas le choix
elles ont fait elles se sont lancées
dans le quantitative easing dans la
planche à billets à partir de 2009 et
c'était c'était le le
dès le premier jour si vous voulez
c'était trop tard on est tombé dedans on
est tombé dans un système de drogue
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois votre
tentative easing le cantal or c'est
aussi rendre en fait c'est faire
fonctionner la planche à billets pour
aller acheter des obliques sur le marché
avec une idée derrière la tête qui était
de se dire si on rachète des obliques
sur le marché ça va permettre aux
banques qui vont avoir des liquidités de
les prêter alors ça c'est toujours le
grand truc c'est de se dire que dans la
halle
la théorie économique c'est c'est de se
dire si les taux baissent les
entreprises vont emprunter mais non moi
je suis entrepreneur
si vous voulez vous pouvez me coller les
taux à zéro c'est pas pour ça que je
vais emprunter je vais emprunter si j'ai
des marchés je vais emprunter si j'ai
des clients je vais emprunter si je dois
faire un investissement mais je vais pas
emprunter parce que les taux sont passés
de 3 c'est pas vrai et ça n'existe dans
aucun donc aucune entreprise mais
évidemment ces gens là ceux qui sont à
la tête des banques centrales n'ont
jamais géré d'entreprise ils ont appris
l'économie dans des bouquins et
malheureusement ça marche pas comme dans
le book
voilà un mois justement sur la banque
centrale européenne alors au moment où
on enregistre cette émission il vient
d'avoir quelques annonces de la bce qui
ont plutôt fait plonger encore davantage
les bourses européennes un mot justement
sur ces mesures qui semblent avoir été
prises dans un premier temps peut-être
que ça suivra d'autres d'autres mesures
120 milliards d'achats de dette publique
109 120 milliards d'achats et de l'autre
côté on maintient des taux bas alors oui
prêts pour les pme de toute façon
maintenant coincé pour coincer et on vit
sous perfusion de toute façon si vous
coupez la perf du jour au lendemain
c'est c'est fini donc ils sont coincés
mais le problème avec ça c'est que si on
reste dans cette logique
en fait ce qu'il nous faut c'est
exactement ce qui a toujours été fait et
ce qui est la cause profonde de la crise
et de nous dire il va falloir soutenir
la demande parce que c'est une crise de
demandes et on va inciter les gens à
s'endetter mais le coeur du problème
c'est la dette c'est qu'on vit autant on
a vécu au dessus de nos moyens parce que
l'argent est faux et en fait ce qui se
passe sur les places financières
est ce que récupère les entreprises n'a
aucun rapport avec les fondamentaux réel
donc mécaniquement on comprend qu'ils
aient une inquiétude c'est peut-être
même un bon signe c'est que les marchés
se disent bon ben c'est
pas la bonne solution c'est pas ça qu'il
faut faire vous pouvez pas nous refaire
une forme de quantitative easing ou la
réinjection à la veuve de monnaies parce
que finalement vous vous êtes juste en
train de recréer une bulle alors soit
c'est pris comme ça et c'est bon signe
soit l'avenir nous dit qu'en fait c'est
qu'on attend encore plus et c'est très
mauvais signe ça veut dire qu'on avait
en fait des entreprises zombies que
comme on a au japon qui ne vivent que
grâce à de la dette et qui attendent
plus de dettes parce qu'il voit qu'avec
ce niveau-là ça suffira pas et là là
c'est très mauvais signe que je crois
aujourd'hui que les marchés attendent
réellement le signal que la banque
centrale est toute puissante et il
semble alors on pourrait dire en voyant
la baisse des cours que le marché a
compris qu'en fait la banque centrale a
perdu la main
mais je j'ai peur quand même que ce soit
1 la deuxième opposition c'est à dire
que le marché 10 mhz en face c'est
inadmissible elle n'a pas baissé les
taux en même temps et c'est alors qu'on
s'attendait à des mesures encore plus
fortes
on s'attendait en gros à ce que madame
lagarde disent à écouter s'il faut me
milliards pour remonter on mettra 1000
milliards s'il en faut 5 milles on en
mettra cinq mille c'est ça qu'ils
attendraient pas le marché ce qui n'est
pas le cas mais vous inquiétez pas ça va
venir c'est à dire que dans les semaines
à venir si on continue sur ce rythme là
il est évident que vous allez avoir une
action concertée des banques centrales
qui vont vous dire écoutez voilà on est
là nos limites comme l'avait dit draghi
nos limites
s'il faut cinq mille milliards on mettra
cinq mille milliards s'il en faut dix
mille on en mettra dix mille parce que
au final vous n'avez pas de formules
mathématiques qui vous disent à partir
d'un certain ton assez delà de la banque
centrale va à partir d'un certain
montant de bilan de la banque centrale
la monnaie ne vaut plus rien donc c'est
juste une crise de confiance et on ne
sait absolument pas quand la confiance
va disparaître et donc au final pourquoi
pas avoir un bilan de banques centrales
et gallo pib de la zone ou plus haut que
le pib de la zone parce que vous sortez
dans la rue ou prenez 10 personnes vous
leur dites demain
le bilan de la banque centrale
européenne à des phases de 4700 à 10000
milliards
je doute que les gens se roulent par
terre en crise d'épilepsie 1
ils vont vous dire bah oui et alors bon
voilà donc ça passe
le les banques centrales le savent et
donc elles vont en profiter
un mot sur l'économie réelle justement
va essayer de pardon d'aller un peu plus
dans le concret on a pour sa part un
extrait d'un discours de bruno le maire
le ministre de l'économie c'était le 9
mars dernier
il a détaillé les secteurs en france qui
sont le plus touchés par cette crise
vous propose de l'écouter dès la
mi-février a fortiori début mars
nous voyons un impact très directe de
l'épidémie de couronnes à virus sur
notre économie
l'impact se chiffrera en plusieurs
dixièmes de points de pib pour
l'économie française
un certain nombre de secteurs sont très
durement touchée et l'impact et violents
pour ces secteurs qui étaient présents
ce matin je vous donne quelques chiffres
qui vont été donnée par les
professionnels il ya quelques instants
c'est des baisses de chiffre d'affaires
de 60 % en moyenne pour les créateurs de
30 à 40% dans l'hôtellerie de 25% en
moyenne pour les restaurateurs et des
chiffres encore plus fort pour tout le
secteur de l'événementiel puisque les
des annulations se font aujourd'hui en
cascade dans ce secteur-là
on vient d'entendre l'événementiel le
tourisme première impacté de cette crise
alors bruno le maire parle d'un choc
massif mondiale et violent il annoncé
quelques mesures notamment un fonds de
solidarité pour les entreprises les plus
touchées à l'échelle de la france
qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir être fait selon
vous pour tenter d'endiguer cette crise
on peut on peut tenter de répliquer ce
que l'on fait au niveau global ça c'est
ça c'est jouable le problème avec ça
c'est que il faut en fait il faudrait
arriver à discriminer quelles sont les
entreprises qui se trouve dans une crise
qui est vraiment conjoncturel qu'est-ce
qui quels sont les secteurs qu'on peut
aider et en fait au sein des secteurs
vraiment identifier les entreprises
mais si on essaye de fournir des aides
comme ça à global on recrée exactement
le même problème on revient sur l'idée
de départ d'aléa moral on va faire
survivre des entreprises qui en fait
sont pas viables donc
ensuite elles sont obligées de vivre
qu'avec de l'aide donc ça veut dire plus
d'être plus de dette c'est à dire
potentiellement plus d'impôts qui vont
refréner ça veut dire ça veut dire de la
liquidité qui est fausse
et comme en plus on peut on n'est pas
maître de notre monnaie ça veut dire de
toute façon et une incapacité à gérer
ensuite d'évaluer potentiellement avoir
de l'inflation
donc il faut faire très attention ici en
fait ce qu'il nous faudrait même si
c'est c1 faisable c'est une utopie mais
il ne faudrait une armée d'analystes
qu'il soit capable de discriminer de
vraiment voir quelles sont les
entreprises dont les fondamentaux sont
bons et le problème est conjoncturelle
quelles sont celles qui de toute façon
était destiné à mourir mais si on fait
pas ça de toute façon on n'aura rien
résolu à la fin et alors c'est l'une des
conséquences un peu inattendu de cette
crise on a appris le 11 mars dernier que
la privatisation des aéroports de paris
était suspendu à porte parole du
gouvernement si bête ndiaye a expliqué
que cette privatisation je cite ne
saurait se poser dans l'immédiat compte
tenu des conditions actuelles du marché
on imagine bien pourquoi
olivier est ce qu on peut donc dire que
le virus a réussi là où la pétition
avait échoué qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise tant mieux tant mieux
c'était c'était une escroquerie patenté
cette histoire de 70 années mans s'est
rependue s'est pas encore heureux et non
mais espérons que ça dure
espérons que le marché continue de
chuter pour qu'on n'ait pas la
prévisualisation da bp et que en effet
certains ne s'en mettent pas plein les
fouilles sur sur une sur une aberration
moi je suis pas contre les
privatisations si vous voulez mais je
suis contre les escroqueries en revanche
et là c'en était une
j'habite est un mot sur juste pour
rester un peu dans ce domaine là sur la
réforme des retraites il ya un certain
nombre de personnes aussi qui
s'inquiètent du fait que avec cette
crise financière la réforme des
retraites puisse en être à paqueter
votre avis ça pourrait être le cas
le problème c'est que rien que la
question montre que les gens qui sont
inquiets de ça on continuer à mélanger
le fait que cette réforme est le
la faillite news de la capitalisation
des ces paliers on reste dans un système
de répartition par contre sur le plan
économique purement stratégique si
vraiment il fallait réformer aujourd'hui
alors attends donc tout s'effondre et
passons la capitalisation ce sera le
moment de faire son marché
on capitalise ça ne pourra pas être plus
bas si on est dans une crise donc les
choses remonteront et on gagnera de
l'argent facilement mais c'est mais ça
c'est vrai si on est dans un système de
capitalisation autrement il n'y a pas
d'intérêt à s'inquiéter de sa de toute
façon on va vivre au nom si on a une
crise on a une crise et il les retraites
seront pas directement impactés par ça
puisqu'on place rien nous très bien
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pierre bernès à nous
avoir accompagnés pour décrypter les
conséquences économiques donc lié à
cette pandémie de coronavirus merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission je
rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission consacrée donc au
coronavirus sur rt france pour tv vous
pouvez ici aussi réagir à cette émission
avec le hashtag rt cash
olivier comme le veut l'usagé le mot de
la fin est pour bat écoutez il ya une
pénurie de j'ai le droit l'hydro
alcoolique
donc je vous conseille de mettre du
pastis dans l'eau ça vous fera un sérum
à hydro alcoolique avec modération
voilà